madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce vendredi 13 avril
la fin de l'espoir pour la famille et
les proches de sophie gravaud
le corps de la jeune fille de 23 ans a
été retrouvé cet après midi à quelques
kilomètres du lieu de sa disparition le
couple suspect a été mis en examen et
écroué ce soir attention dépassements
d'honoraires de plus en plus de médecins
les pratiquent essentiellement les
spécialistes des soins qui coûte donc de
plus en plus cher pour les malades
un vendredi de campagne marquée par deux
propositions en forme de bouteille à la
mer lancée à gauche et à droite pourquoi
pas une dose de proportionnelle dans le
mode de scrutin
voilà l'idée du bras droit de nicolas
sarkozy brice hortefeux
et pourquoi pas une alliance avant le
premier tour entre ségolène royal et
françois bayrou
l'idée est signée cette fois michel
rocard un automne et un hiver sec un
printemps ensoleillé et on parle déjà de
sécheresse dans le sud du pays
aujourd'hui les températures étaient
estivale au nord 25 degrés à paris lille
et strasbourg
il a toujours sa voix basse et son
accent suisse allemand stephan eicher
est de retour dixième album déjà et un
nouveau complice pour l'écriture
raphaël extraits et rencontre à la fin
de ce journal c'est donc bien le corps
de sophie gravaud qui a été découvert
cet après midi en bordure d'une route
départementale près de nantes
la jeune femme de 23 ans disparue depuis
samedi a été retrouvé par un promeneur à
quelques kilomètres seulement du centre
commercial où elle travaille et ce soir
le principal suspect a rejoint son
épouse en prison aurélia guillemin et
mathias second le corps de la jeune
femme a été découvert ici par un
promeneur face contre terre en partie
dévêtue la victime gisait dans un fossé
en bordure de nationale à une dizaine de
kilomètres du lieu de sa disparition
difficile pour l'instant de déterminer
les causes de la mort mais des traces au
niveau du cou font penser à une
strangulation
elle était sans vie quand elle a été
déposé ici ce corps porte des ecchymoses
et notamment à l'intérieur des gendres
ce qui laisserait à penser qu'il y a pu
y avoir une résistance à une agression
sexuelle
la police scientifique épaulé par une
vingtaine de gendarmes a ratissé la
scène de crime à la recherche du moindre
indice qui pourrait permettre de
confondre l'auteur d'essais car le
suspect numéro un a présenté ce matin au
juge d'instruction a continué de nier
toute implication dans cette affaire
il devrait être mise en examen pour
enlèvement et séquestration suivis de
mort et a été incarcéré à nantes
tout comme sa compagne devant le mutisme
des deux principaux accusés les
enquêteurs mise désormais sur des traces
adn relevées sur les sous-vêtements de
sophie gravaud
depuis la disparition de la jeune femme
samedi dernier ses amis se rassembler
chaque jour pour distribuer son portrait
dans les rues de nantes
c'est là qu'ils ont appris la terrible
nouvelle cet après midi sous le choc ils
appellent à une marche silencieuse en sa
mémoire et demain avec son provence le
verdict vient de tomber ce soir dans la
sphère ghofrane haddaoui cette jeune
femme de 23 ans avait été tuée à coups
de pierres marseille en 2004 et bien la
cour d'assises dès mineurs des bouches
du rhône a reconnu coupable les deux
jeunes hommes qui comparaissaient ils
ont tous deux été condamné à 23 ans de
réclusion
l'avocat général avait requis la peine
massique maximale soit 30 ans de prison
je suis toujours avec ce rebondissement
aujourd'hui dans la sphère du gardien de
la paix tués lundi soir à la foire du
trône à paris
on avait d'abord évoqué la thèse du
simple accident et bien aujourd'hui les
déclarations d'un jeune homme mineur âgé
de 15 ans infirme ce scénario le jeune
homme aurait avoué avoir poussé le
gardien de la paix christelle bertrand
karine comazzi et charles baget
quatre jours après la mort du policier
reynald caron à la foire du trône
les enquêteurs pensent avoir trouvé le
responsable c'est un adolescent connu
des services de police selon ses proches
il peut avoir de violentes colères il a
été retrouvé en province loin de son
quartier d'evry
nous avons produit de la part des
principaux protagonistes des aveux
notamment garçon qui aura 16 ans dans
quelques semaines a reconnu avoir poussé
reynald caron pour échapper sans doute à
une interpellation
ce garçon a donc peu l'ont porté
volontairement des coûts une poussée
volontaires dirigés contre le
fonctionnaire de police le jeune homme
devrait être mis en examen pour coups et
blessures volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort sur un policier sans intention de
la donner un crime passible de 20 ans de
prison
avec lui une autre personne devrait être
mise en examen et écrouée pour avoir
frappé un deuxième policier
enfin deux autres hommes devraient être
poursuivis pour avoir provoqué la
bagarre initial avec les forains ce soir
on est loin de la thèse accidentelle
privilégiée quelques heures après le
drame
tous les policiers c'est important de
connaître la vérité ce qu'on veut c'est
savoir ce qui s'est passé il s'agit pas
de faire porter une accusation qui n'est
pas juste il s'agit pas non plus de
laisser échapper des gens qui ont une
lourde responsabilité dans la mort de ce
policier
reynald caron était âgé de 31 ans il
appartenait à une unité parisienne de
gardiens de la paix affecté à la
sécurité de la foire du trône depuis son
décès des renforts ont été déployés
les images maintenant d'une
reconstitution quel lieu l'année
dernière à huis clos à marseille
reconstitution de cet incendie criminel
d'un bus qui avait grièvement brûlé en
octobre dernier la jeune mama galedou la
jeune femme de 26 ans n'était pas
présente en raison toujours de son état
de santé
ce jour-là huit jeunes tous mineurs au
moment des faits était monté dans le bus
pour provoquer un incendie hier soir les
témoignages ont divergé
l'un des adolescents accusés à un autre
d'être à l'origine de l'incendié
les autres sont restés silencieux par
peur de représailles selon leur avocat
c'est une pratique légale mais cette
fois certains médecins sont ils allés
trop loin dans son usage l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales igas est
en passe de rendre un rapport accablant
sur les dépassements d'honoraires
jenny briffa et jean francois monier ce
généraliste fixe librement ses prix de
totalement gratuite pour les plus
modestes ces consultations sont
généralement à 34 euros soit 13 euros de
plus que le tarif fixé par la sécurité
sociale
à partir du moment où le médecin
respecte le code de déontologie cdja
qu'ils respectent bien le pouvoir et
financier du malade je pense pas que 10
euros de plus soit pénalisant pour pour
lui la les dépassements d'honoraires
atteignent désormais 2 milliards d'euros
selon un rapport de l'inspection des
affaires sociales
révélée par le point en 15 ans les
dépassements ont doublé en médecine de
ville passant de 763 millions d'euros à
plus d'un milliard et demi en 2005
aujourd'hui un tiers des spécialistes
sont en honoraires libres
mais il existe de fortes disparités
régionales la même ainsi 58% en
ile-de-france contre 46 % en rhône-alpes
ou 12 % en bretagne
parmi les spécialistes les plus
concernés les gynécologues pour eux ces
déplacements ne sont qu'un rattrapage
les prix des consultations étaient
bloqués pendant 15 ans est-ce que ça
c'est pas choquant c'est choquant
quelque part le marché puisque c'est un
marché libérale mais il faut s'est
autorégulée alors il ya des brebis
galeuses
librairie gars ne sont pas très
nombreuses je pense pas qu'il faille
taper sur tout le système parce que
quelques brebis galeuses
problème ces dépassements ne sont que
partiellement remboursés par les
mutuelles pour l'inspection des affaires
sociales
il accroche donc les inégalités dans
l'accès aux soins à l'étranger
alger toujours en état de choc après le
double attentat qui a fait 33 morts
mercredi dans la capitale algérienne
les attentats je vous le rappelle
revendiqué par al-qaïda est commis par
trois kamikazes
aujourd'hui les premiers enterrements de
victimes avaient lieu nous envoyés
spéciaux sur place samah soula et noura
geely toutes les mosquées d'alger on
raisonnait d'une même prière à la
mémoire des victimes des attentats
une influence hebdomadaires habituels
qui oblige les fidèles à prier à
l'extérieur de l'édifice
tous les imams ont reçu la même consigne
centré leurs prêches sur la condamnation
des attentes a appelé à la paix et à la
réconciliation
ces actes terroristes revendiqués par al
qaïda au nom de l'islam révolte les
fidèles l'islam mais jamais de la vie
celui qui tue un musulman ne voit pas
d'intérêt d'al qaïda de frapper en
algérie l'algérie est à un mois d'un
scrutin législatif rumeurs et hypothèses
vont bon train la sécurité est l'enjeu
numéro un pour les autorités même
préoccupation pour les français
installés en algérie vigiles contrôle à
l'entrée du troquet ce restaurant tenu
par un marseillais resaler en algérie
depuis dix ans mais ça ne m'empêchera
pas de rester ici et de continuer à
travailler ou à l'algérie chez installés
ici c'est devenu
une famille j'ai mes affaires c'est mon
pays bonjour cela
jean-claude qu'une jolie avait fait le
choix de venir en algérie quand tous
l'avait quitté il ya 14 mois un nouveau
chef cuisinier français l'a rejoint sur
google partout dans le monde entier
donc je sois ici ou en france en
revanche paru avec ce sentiment que le
risque zéro n'existe désormais nulle
part l' enquête sur ce double attentat
s'annonce longue et difficile
la police algérienne ne dispose que de
lambeaux de vêtements et de bouts de
ferraille et les kamikazes présumés
seraient trop jeune pour avoir été fiché
par les services de renseignements et la
france face à cette menace terroriste
doit elle s'inquiéter on se souvient
qu'en septembre dernier le numéro deux
d'al qaïda ayman al zawahiri avait
explicitement visé je cite la france
infidèle dans une déclaration publique
le pays semble toujours selon les
responsables de la lutte antiterroriste
une cible potentielle voyons pourquoi
avec frank g 2o et patrie desmulie c'est
une attention de tous les instants
le plan vigipirate est au niveau rouge
depuis les attentats de londres en 2005
et cela ne devrait pas changer après les
attentats d'alger il ya deux jours en
septembre dernier la mouvance al qaida
vias ayman al zawahiri son numéro deux a
intégré le gspc algérien dont l'émir ici
sur des images de propagande a plusieurs
fois menacé la syrie il est reproché à
la france plusieurs choses
son engagement en afghanistan au titre
des forces de la coalition
la prise de position quant aux signes
des ports extérieur religieux dans les
écoles
est ce qu'on appelait la loi sur le
voile islamique la france a déjà été
confronté au terrorisme islamique à
travers la vague d'attentats de 1995
pour éviter ce scénario les services de
police multiplie les interpellations en
amont comme ici à trappes en 2005 en
cinq ans 548 personnes ont été arrêtées
cent cinquante ont par la suite été
incarcère la nécessité d'interpeller
pour les individus qui gravitent autour
de ces noyaux informel va permettre aux
services de faire la différence entre
ceux qui sont véritablement engagés dans
l'action violente est ce simplement
qu'ils se trouvent à leur contact
par sympathie personnelle ou
idéologiques
la priorité est désormais aux
renseignements depuis dix ans les
autorités de l'antiterrorisme estiment
avoir déjoué plusieurs attentats par an
en irak al-qaïda a également revendiqué
l'attentât suicide qui a touché hier le
parlement de bagdad située dans le
centre pourtant très protégée de la
ville
un attentat a fait au moins un mort et
plusieurs blessés et bien malgré cela le
parlement s'est réuni ce matin en
session extraordinaire une façon
d'adresser jeudi un message clair à tous
les terroristes
jacques chirac s'est entretenu l'année
dernière au téléphone avec son homologue
afghan hamid karzaï
et cela afin de lui demander son soutien
pour la libération des deux otages
français toujours retenus par les
talibans actuellement il faut savoir que
la france est toujours présente
militairement sur le sol afghan
mais également en mer ainsi le
porte-avion charles-de-gaulle évolué en
ce moment au large du pakistan à bord
notre équipe dorothée cochard et
frédéric bohn
depuis près de quarante jours les avions
français de la marine patrouille en
afghanistan le charles de gaulle est en
pleine opération militaire bras armé de
la coalition internationale
les missions sont quotidiennes
éprouvante
elles durent cinq à six heures chacune
le plus compliqué c'est de s'approprier
une zone quand on y arrive parce qu'on
n'est pas spécialiste du terrain en fait
un terrain montagneux et désertique à la
fois où les taliban constitue un risque
permanent un risque lié aux capacités
des gens au sol de leur tirer dessus
avec des armes alors bon avec des petits
calibres c'est pas un gros risque parce
que généralement nous avions restent
très haut mais maintenant s'il y avait
des missiles sol-air courte portée
ça ferait partie des risques de toute
façon on a déjà pris en compte
concrètement le charles de gaulle
fournissait super étendard et 3 rafale
dernier cri de l'armée française équipés
de bombes guidées laser leur mission est
de soutenir les troupes au sol de la
coalition internationale
le charles de gaulle évolué à une
centaine de kilomètres au sud des côtes
pakistanaises
les avions remonte vers le nord longe la
frontière iranienne et viennent évolué
au sud de l'afghanistan
chacune des missions et confidentiel
minutieusement préparé
on est passé au dessus du convoi qui va
de caen va jusqu à garance et un
scénario de base qui changent souvent
les avions évolué en fonction des
besoins au sol c'est-à-dire des attaques
des talibans
mais les bombardements sont rares ils ne
sont qu'un dernier recours du convoi ces
survols sont là pour donner un ultime
avertissement aux talibans dans
attention la présence d'aéronefs est
avérée et nous son père et intervenir
occasion
la mission du charles de gaulle se veut
donc dissuasive avant d'être offensive
réunion importante et essentielle même
dans un contexte particulièrement
délicat
les deux français retenus en otages en
afghanistan sont toujours aux mains des
talibans et puis je vous le disais au
début de ce journal le verdict vient de
tomber dans la sphère ghofrane haddaoui
on retrouve tout de suite stéphane
despinoy annexe des peines lourdes donc
pour danser ce soir stéphane oui alors
vous imaginez avec quel soulagement la
famille de coffrane a accueilli ce
verdict aux cris d' ailleurs de justice
pour ghofrane alors 23 ans pour les deux
jeunes qui ont participé au crime qui
s'est commis dans les quartiers nord de
marseille en octobre 2004 c'est à dire
que l'excusé de minorité n'a pas été
retenue à l'époque des faits il avait 16
et 17 ans et l'avocat général avait
demandé à ce que cette excuse ne soit
pas retenue estimant qu'ils étaient tout
à fait conscients des actes qu'ils
avaient commis donc le soulagement je
vous propose d'écouter et tout de suite
la maman de fran ce et monia adawiya
l'instant ici au palais de justice pour
ghofrane et vous savez aujourd'hui il
ajuste ses salles relève la tête
il faut dire que elle peut être très
très fier d'elle parce que ils ont pris
en considération une jeune fille qui
s'est vu mourir voilà tout simplement
merci et justice pis aux fran c'est tout
lâche of mercy stéphanois merci beaucoup
c'était la maman de ghofrane juste
encore une précision elle avait fait du
procès un procès exemplaire notamment en
ce qui concerne la lapidation et elle a
estimé justement que la cour d'assises
en établissant un verdict rigoureux
avait donné raison à cette maman qui
avait elle même mené l'enquêté pour
faire la vérité sur ce drame à obinna
petit s'est produit en 2004 merci pour
toutes ces précisions la page politique
de ce journal avec deux déclarations et
deux ballons d'essai largement commentée
aujourd'hui à gauche tout d'abord
l'initiative est signée michel rocard et
ressemble un pavé dans la mare dans une
interview au journal le monde l'ancien
premier ministre affirme souhaiter une
alliance avant même le premier tour
entre françois bayrou et ségolène royal
réactions très contrastées au ps à l'udf
et chez les verts alexandre kara
frédéric faure
jusqu'ici très discret dans la campagne
michel rocard sort de son silence
une tribune dans le quotidien le monde
qui bouscule les socialistes en appelant
à une alliance immédiate ps centristes
seuls moyens pour michel rocard de
battre nicolas sarkozy
j'appelle donc françois bayrou et
ségolène royal avant le premier tour à
s'exprimer devant les français pour
s'engager dans la voie d'une alliance
sincère et constructive qui défendra au
second tour puis aux législatives un
projet commun d'espoir pour la france en
déplacement à belfort ségolène royal
s'est bien gardé de s'exprimer face aux
caméras mais devant les journalistes
elle promet ni manoeuvre ni tractations
c'est françois hollande qui se charge de
répondre à l'ancien premier ministre de
françois mitterrand
pour le premier secrétaire du ps il n'y
a pas d'alliance concevable entre la
gauche et une partie de la droite
une idée également rejeté par les baies
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour michel
rocard
je crois qu'il se trompe il est hors de
question de commencer à négocier quoi
que ce soit avant d'assister à une
premier cours du premier tour si la
gauche veut gagner doit être courageuse
elle doit se battre sur ses malheurs
en revanche le candidat bayrou saisi la
proposition au vol il n'en demandait pas
tant depuis des mois les françaises
disent est ce que françois bayrou nous
propose c'est intéressant mais est ce
que c'est possible
eh bien ils ont aujourd'hui la réponse
la réponse vient d'un des responsables
du parti socialiste les plus importants
qui dit évidemment c'est possible de
tendre la main par dessus les frontières
du passé et de travailler ensemble
à neuf jours du premier tour l'appel de
michel rocard peut-il vraiment être
entendu par les socialistes sans risque
et d'affaiblir ségolène royal autre
prise de position du jour qui suscite de
nombreux commentaires dans une interview
au journal le figaro brice hortefeux
l'un des plus proches collaborateurs de
nicolas sarkozy s'interroge sur la
possibilité d'une dose de
proportionnelle dans le scrutin
majoritaire très vite ségolène royal a
réagi accusant je cite l'ump de négocier
en douce avec le front national du côté
du parti nicolas sarkozy on a également
très vite souhaité rappeler que ces
propos de brice hortefeux n'engageaient
que lui ce soir le camp dial l'ump est
en meeting à meaux alors michael darmon
vous êtes sur place
où en est-on ce soir de cette question
la proportionnelle avancée par brice
hortefeux
et bien laurent ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que cette initiative de brice
hortefeux a pour le moins jeter le
trouble autour du candidat nicolas
sarkozy ce matin à ses proches fort
mécontent d'ailleurs il a martelé qu'il
ne cherchait pas d'accord politique avec
le front national même si ses électeurs
il ya un instant d'ailleurs de le
rappeler et si en meeting même si ce
sont ses électeurs qui l'intéressent
alors bien évidemment cette initiative a
été interprété comme un ballon d'essai
par ses adversaires ségolène royal
l'accusent de négocier en douce avec le
front national tandis que jean marie le
pen lui rejette cette idée tout en
laissant entendre qu'il peut parler avec
nicolas sarkozy
bref à dix jours du premier tour cette
affaire dessine un peu plus le chemin
choisi par le candidat de l'ump
c'est à dire pouvoir attirer sur son nom
dès le premier tour les électeurs du
front national avant de tenter de
rassembler au delà de la droite au
second tour
une entreprise risquée merci michael
darmon la faire du parachute doré de
l'ancien président de erds noël forgeard
a alimenté cette semaine la campagne
voyons justement comment les habitants
de thiais que nous suivons depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines réagissent
à ces sommes astronomiques cette fois
sur cette question pas ou peu de débats
j marine et lionel langlade au bar de
l'espérance le franc a la vie dure et il
a fallu ce matin-là sortir la calculette
mais c'est 50 50 2 millions
de quoi s'offrir attia une quarantaine
de pavillons au mieux ce parachute doré
laisse perplexe ça peut se justifier si
on voit un immense service à la société
se justifier mais il faut justement
regarder si ce service est efficace
devant la supérette voisine le ton est
plus direct sans fil et les employés
sont licenciés fut rien et les patrons
et puis je dévie million et demi d'eau à
dire un million et demi les bons coups à
deux immeubles de la madeleine militante
associative qui préparent des colis pour
certaines familles de la cité ne
décolère pas ça me met hors de moi ça me
scandalise
quand je pense au salaire que gagnent
les gens ici qui est à peine le suit
l'éloigner qui fait il n'y arrive pas
alors que certaines autres personnes
d'un âge dans le pactole
il devrait partager dans un autre
quartier le gérant du garage renault
n'est pas tendre lui non plus à propos
des indemnités
il se chiffre en millions même s'ils ont
fait beaucoup d'études pense que c'est
déraisonnable d'avoir un si gros
salaires en partant au bout de quelques
années vous vous sentez quelque chose de
commun avec ses patrons qu'aucun pas du
tout du tout d'autres chefs d'entreprise
comme ce patron du btp considère en
revanche que la polémique est secondaire
lui millions pour pas se focaliser là
dessus je pense que si la duch choses
plus importantes
justement finalement quelque chose la
plus importante pour vous dans cette
campagne allègement des charges pour les
petites entreprises
place de la mairie les jeunes qui
déambulent ce soir là se veut le
fataliste nous affrontons boys la france
dont plusieurs ça comme ça
si l'essai de la gagne l'argent c'est
que l'ingénierie de footballeur pourquoi
les choses play ball en argentine gueule
c'est l'argent qui génère c'est la même
chose d'une certaine compréhension à la
colère les parachutes dorés à thiais
n'ont pas laissé indifférent à quelques
jours seulement du premier tout il a
fait beau et chaud une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui jusqu'à 25 degrés à paris
strasbourg ou encore à lille et météo
france prévoit pour demain à lille
justement 27 degrés soit 10 degrés au
dessus des normales saisonnières
et une fois n'est pas coutume c'est le
sud et la côte d'azur qui ont connu un
temps plus frais et la pluie aujourd'hui
les averses qui ne compenseront pas le
déficit de précipitations enregistrées
une nouvelle fois cet hiver et à
l'automne dans le var on parle déjà
clairement de sécheresse reportage
roquebrune sur argens nathalie jourdan
et raymond chapelât désormais l'eau qui
remplira ce bassin viendra uniquement du
ciel toutes les fontaines du village
doivent être coupés aux brunes sur
argent l'une des soixante treize
communes varoises placé par la
préfecture en situation d' alerte
sécheresse que les années précédentes
également nous sommes soumis à ceci que
ce serait ce un samedi et
malheureusement est généralement chez
telle est l'impression c'était beaucoup
plus tardivement que lorsque la mesure
vient de prêter en 2006 ce n'est que fin
juin que le var avait été classé en
situation d' alerte des restrictions
d'eau dès le mois d'avril ici c'est
plutôt bien compris en a besoin d'eau
donc c'est vrai que c'est des bonnes
diffusion à prendre et que tout le monde
soit conscient 2003 puis 2005
dix mille hectares partis en fumée
autour de la commune la sécheresse et
les feux ont marqué les mémoires et des
arbres il n'a guère plu depuis 2003 et
le niveau des rivières n'est pas très
haut alors depuis ce matin il est
interdit d'arroser son jardin entre 10h
et 18h et pour remplir sa piscine
il faut une autorisation écrite du maire
ces mesures que vous comprenez oui mais
il va falloir l'aménager ou alors il
faut supprimer toutes les piscines de la
région si on peut pas si on peut pas
remettre à niveau on peut plus les faire
tourner on peut plus entretenir l'eau
sont plus utilisables pour l'instant il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude concernant l'eau
potable avril réservera peut-être de
bonnes surprises aux varois
aujourd'hui il a plu toute la journée
à quoi ressemblent les fonds sous-marins
des régions polaires un photographe
biologiste de formation a plongé pour
découvrir et photographié dans une eau
glaciale des poissons qui n'existe nulle
part ailleurs la faune mais également la
flore images et rencontres étonnantes
laurence de chef frédéric faure les
pôles magnétiques agissent comme des
aimants sur lui
ce jeune photographe est attiré par
l'arctique et l'antarctique pas pour ce
qui se passe au dessus mais plutôt par
40 mètres de fond là où il fait presque
-2° et où seule sa lampe torche brise
l'obscurité la plus totale
là c'est le déclic les seules couleurs
de ces continent blanc et bleu elles
sont à grande profondeur et ça ressemble
vraiment à des récifs coralliens on
trouve des éponges géantes un tronc jeu
des gorgones du corail
elle incarne vraiment le miracle du
vivant comment réussir à créer la vie
dans des conditions aussi hostile à la
vie ce qu'on y découvre ses des aliens
concédé un extraterrestre une
qu'apprennent géante un gorgos eiffage
du grand nord ou des dragons qui vivent
en pleine léthargie dragon rouge
il a de l'antigel dans le sang tout
simplement parce que l'eau a encore une
fois est en dessous des point de
congélation classique d'autres le dragon
menus quand on s'approche de lui ne fuit
pas parce que finalement fuir demande
tellement d'énergie que ça peut être
plus fatale à l'arrivée que de subir le
prédateur l'arctique a déjà perdu 40% de
son épaisseur de glace avec le
réchauffement climatique alors ce
biologiste de formation s'inquiète pour
la faune sous marine
qu'est ce qui va se passer là dessus ces
animaux qui vivaient dans l'obscurité ci
était adapté donc ils vont être
renforcés mans remplacé par d'or qu'ils
vont disparaître
il va forcément y avoir des grands
problèmes au niveau de la biodiversité
que ce soit en arctique ou en
antarctique
les millions d'espèces menacées sans
jamais avoir été rencontrés cet
aventurier s'est lancé un défi
cartographier ces zones et créer le
premier répertoire du peuple sous marins
des régions polaires au pôle nord
toujours cette fois pour le marathon des
glaces qui est comme son nom l'indiqué
la course la plus froide du monde des
dizaines de courageux chaudement vêtu
par les moins 25 degrés ambiants ont
pris le départ le vainqueur est en
irlande elle a parcouru les 42 km 195 en
trois ans de 6 minutes et 10 secondes
soit le record depuis la création de la
course
musique avec la sortie du nouvel album
de stephan eicher les rythmes de cette
fois son jazzy rock et l'ambiance douce
et feutrée et les textes toujours signée
philippe djian mais également une
nouveauté
raphaël extraits et rencontres olivenza
et dominique bonnet partout dans le
monde il y a toujours une écossaise pour
reconnaître le plus français des
chanteurs sus en français en allemand
j'adore l'écouter le soleil d'une table
l'endroit idéal pour déjeuner en paix
en plus
un tube puis 2-3 ce n'est plus un
déjeuner mais un festin dans les années
90 stephan eicher est une star
on entre dans cette côte d'azur hic
après dix mis en pointillés
le revoici avec un appétit tout neuf
j'essaie de faire des aspirines comme ça
musical c'est un peu mal à la tête ou
mal de quelque chose on comprend pas un
médicament française ça va pas nous
guérir mèze sa thèse ses premiers succès
il les doit à l'écrivain philippe jan
aujourd'hui stéphane eicher reçoit le
concours d'un autre compositeur que tout
le monde s'arrache en vain raphaël lui a
pourtant dit on
réparer
et lui offre cette chanson
c'est le chemin
le chemin
me dit rien
ces deux là tu étais super spa sont pas
des deux comme tuer des faits c'était
mieux ce sont des coups bas
je crois avec rappel on a trouvé cette
personne qui qui amène à cette chose
cette jeunesse est cette croyance à
quelque chose de mieux
je pense encore et pas l'espoir devant
meilleur abattues les 7 partis ont
combattu les
là il a retrouvé une seconde jeunesse a
intitulé son album el dorado comme une
promesse le temps du renouveau
les plaindre a appris ce soir la mort de
pierre proches le père de caroline il
est l auteur de l illustrateur des
albums de la célèbre petite fille à la
seule patte rouge
les 43 album retraçant les aventures de
caroline se sont rendus à 38 millions
d'exemplaires pierre propre avec 94
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi tout de suite questions
ouvertes arlette laguiller répond aux
questions de gilles leclerc et jean
baptiste auprès d'ali la mettez l'eau
isabelle martinez suivi du point route
de julien pascale à 21 heures une soirée
de polar avec pj puis avocat y associer
demain 13h olivier galzi vos coups à 20
heures belle soirée à vous
une année de cours